" Eh, vous recevez la télé
par une antenne râteau ?
Pas de panique, il faut juste vérifier
si votre télé est prête
pour le passage à la TNT HD. "
La TNT, c'est une nouvelle
naissance pour LCP.
On parle beaucoup de la révolution
technologique que ça représentait.
Cette possibilité d'avoir 17, 18,
20, 27, etc, chaînes gratuites.
Mais surtout, c'est pour ceux
qui arrivent, une exigence programmatique.
Et donc il fallait que LCP devienne
cet objet télévisuel attractif grand public
à la faveur de la TNT.
" Nous venons de presser le bouton
qui symboliquement marque
ce basculement dans le numérique,
c'est-à-dire 18 chaînes,
un meilleur son, une meilleure image.
Je crois que c'est vraiment
une nouvelle étape de l'aventure télévisuelle. "
Moi j'arrive à la direction de l'antenne et
des programmes de LCP à ce moment-là,
c'est le premier discours
que je tiens aux équipes ici
en leur disant : mais vous avez
un truc génial qui vous arrive
attention, c'est un cadeau formidable
si la chaîne ne se transforme pas
comme elle doit se transformer
à la faveur de cette TNT,
ça peut se retourner contre vous.
On ne pouvait plus se contenter simplement
de mettre 3 personnes autour d'une table
de poser des questions, etc.
Donc il fallait sortir,
il fallait aller voir la France
il fallait aller voir le monde.
" Quittons maintenant pour quelques instants,
l'Hémicycle, l'Hexagone et les ministères
direction l'Inde avec
cette délégation parlementaire française
partie rencontrer le Dalaï-lama. "
Il y avait une équipe de
jeunes journalistes passionnés, etc.
Moi, j'ai fait le choix de construire
une espèce d'alchimie avec des gens
plus aguerris,
des figures de l'audiovisuel.
" - Bonjour à tous !
Une bonne manière
de décrypter l'actualité politique. "
" - Le contrat, c'est le nom
de cette émission. "
Bruno Masure, Giesbert, Pulvar,
Thomas Hervé, John Paul Lepers, etc.
C'est évidemment un grand débat qui
a beaucoup agité ceux qui ont pensé LCP.
Est-ce que d'un côté, on doit être
une chaîne très parlementaire
très vertueuse,
très sérieuse, voilà.
Et de l'autre côté, une chaîne
dévergondée, commerciale...
Non !
On doit être une chaîne
qui s'empare d'une matière.
Encore une fois, la matière parlementaire,
la matière politique, la matière citoyenne.
Et c'est ce travail d'équilibriste,
je dirais, entre l'un et l'autre
qui fait les choses.
" Qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
dissipés ce matin ! "
Ça fait pas des coefficients multiplicateurs,
en termes d'audience, géniaux
mais on sent que le truc bouge.
Et surtout, on sent
que l'image de la chaîne bouge.
Finalement, cette chaîne s'était construite
comme une espèce d'exception.
Et là, elle redevenait aussi
une chaîne parmi les autres.